[Applause]
oh
talking about gates what about uh the
melinda kate's
smear campaign continues on bill this
[ __ ] is rotten
this [ __ ] is rotten is she writing for
him just like cheating relentlessly he
didn't cheat relentlessly asked a couple
holes out after after
over email they said no he was like all
right fine yeah he legit asked him out
once they said no and then he didn't ask
again and what their business means
say what and that's how they were like
business but you're not supposed to yeah
i guess maybe he's a different he comes
with a different generation where you
could [ __ ] your employees
that's what that's how she got on yeah
exactly she was an employee that's
another thing she got to realize
apparently she was upset that there
wasn't like equality in their
relationship
[ __ ] and it's like yeah he saw you as
like you know his employee
and then you became his wife and he was
like oh we're gonna keep that right
[ __ ]
the richest man in the world yeah you
want a quality marry a [ __ ]
uh supervisor at staples yeah yeah yeah
you're not getting equality from the
richest man actually she's just not
strong enough
because because megan mark will flip
that [ __ ] meghan markle was opening up
boxes on that show what's that show
called open
guess the box greatest comment dealer no
deal yeah what's the deal or no deal
what's in the box dealer notes yeah
what's that
that's seven bro what's seven uh
brad pitt what's that oh [ __ ] yeah lit
the wife's head yeah i've never seen it
yeah yeah i know you never said i would
love that movie actually it's absolutely
amazing uh and then
brad pitch is cursing no [ __ ] no
yeah there's an alternate ending on
youtube it
uh that whole scene plays out and then
he goes what's in the box and morgan
freeman looks at the box and looks up
and then you
hear the kirby enthusiasm credits and
it's so [ __ ] funny
that's great um but yeah that's what she
did she used to open boxes
yeah right like people would say like
250 and maybe they guessed her box
and then she would open her box and that
was her job that's the greatest comeback
yeah that was her job and then she
married the prince of england
yeah right well she became a fake lawyer
oh yeah yeah then she became the fake
lawyer and she got married
got divorced she got married another
person she was married before
a manager named trevor engelson do you
know him
my old manager was cool with him and
then that's just such a funny flip
that they were divorced and he was like
out there getting it thinking he's just
[ __ ] living his best life
and she married [ __ ] royalty yep but
he also traded up oh what did he get he
got some
super rich one really so they both did
it say the name say the name
yeah drop it you can't drop it all right
i don't like them
um i don't know what's you guys feeling
on megan
i feel about her exactly how i feel
about the manager guy which is
just yeah they trade it up they trade it
up that's what they did
they traded uh dude she's boss like
i don't know i'm like she's just
unlikable as a person
but she's right about everything she
says
explain just like the royal family sucks
yeah
just agree with that it's like useless
does nothing it's stupid
how unlikable is she yeah that's you're
the only person i know who doesn't like
it
oh have you guys heard her talk she's a
little unlikeable she's unlikeable
comes across a little phony i mean like
yeah it looks like julente
yeah i guess yeah yeah i mean you don't
think so like i don't know
she's just kind of like too cute where
it's like i don't really listen to it
yeah that's
that's how you know she's really
unlikable like she's hot
yeah and she's still unlikable usually
if you're hot it's like okay i can put
up with all this
but even then she's just kind of like
annoying but she's right about
everything
like it's rare that you agree with
somebody and you're annoyed by them